so my background is an accountancy I was
doing it for 12 years even though I'd
done well in my career I knew it's not
what I wanted to be doing forever join
the academy in April last year and then
within a month we had the keys to our
first properties the revenue that we're
bringing in was about three and a half K
that's Madness how do you juggle a
full-time demanding job as a chartered
accountant being a monk and trying to
set up a property business how did you
juggle that building their business
doing one hour a day to bring the baby
to viewings and stuff yeah how much
profit are you making about seven and a
half thousand yeah I mean you make it to
time and age that's when you're supposed
to go and enjoy your life if you haven't
really got energy yet you can quit like
that so now you're not a we
wouldn't be here without you you know
you've changed our lives
lamina and Sadie thanks for coming to my
house no problem you guys are like a
power couple within property dominating
the market financially free and you were
a chartered accountant that's correct
yeah so my background is an accountancy
um I was doing it for 12 years so I
became a chartered accountant did my
Acca qualifications I didn't actually go
to university though kind of always knew
University wasn't for me so I actually
did the whole apprenticeship route okay
whereby I was work it just went straight
into working and got trained up as an
accountant and studied part-time so I
did that worked my way up and became
chartered earned a good salary and and
yeah so that was that was my background
amazing and like do you guys as a couple
do you work together on the property
stuff or do you have different
departments how does it work sorry work
together
um she deals with certain things I deal
with certain things but it's all
together at the same time who was it
that started in property and said this
is what we want to do me yeah what did
you think about that yeah I mean you
know what I've always liked property
anyway I've had my own place before she
had her own place before so we both were
into property anyway but yeah it was
generally her idea and were you
skeptical at all or were you just like
yes no I was I was like yes I was like
let's go let's do this yeah and how did
you first like decide that you wanted to
go full time into property like where
did that how did you how did you go from
accounts to property so for me I I
always knew that even though I'd done
well in my career I knew it's not what I
wanted to be doing forever I didn't want
to be working forever till retirement so
I knew that I wanted to get into
something else and I'd actually tried
other businesses before like I tried
network marketing before I'd done a bit
of trading before but when I heard about
property and I came across you actually
in lockdown I first heard about Samuel
Leeds
um and I joined he had like an online
365 course at the time so I joined that
but I wasn't in the right headspace at
the time it's only when we came down to
to a crash course was it December 2021
we came down to the first crash course
and just hearing like what was possible
and what you can achieve through
property we sort of took our journey
sort of further from then then enrolled
on the essay and HMO course in April
last year watching a lot of your videos
as well yeah yeah back to back back to
back I think it's really important
personally if you want to achieve
something to be around other people that
are doing that how has your environment
changed and how has that helped over
since you got started in property yeah
no it's good to be around like-minded
people just for the fact that they boost
you on keep you going you can have the
right conversations and yeah just talk
to the right people and they just
motivate you I tell you what I've
noticed is if somebody is on a
completely different path to you
even if you're friends you're both going
to live on two complete different lives
if somebody's doing exactly the same
thing as you
you can both be on the same level
motivate each other boost each other's
confidence when you know just yeah so
what was your first deal then when did
that happen so we joined the academy in
April last year and then within a month
we had the keys to our first property so
may that's 2022 yeah really really fast
yeah and tell me talk through how that
happened then like how did you find it
what were the figures before we're
joining the academy we actually was
trying to get rent to essays but it just
wasn't happening
um so once we did the training within a
few weeks we then made it happen so it
was through an estate agent we went and
met the estate agent and it turned out
that that particular property
um it was being let to a company but it
was their employees that were staying in
there but their landlord was open to
company let's so that's how we managed
to sort of persuade the estate agent and
the landlord because they were sort of
already sort of open to it so that was a
really really good deal so with this one
the rent was including bills which was
1500 a month
and then we just had to pay council tax
on top of that
um so all in all our bills came to about
2 000 when you include booking fees
um however the income the revenue that
we're bringing in was about three and a
half K from that property so we're
making about 1500 profit from that
property and it's a beaut it was a
beautiful two-bed apartment
yeah overlooking the lake yeah
yeah when you saw the money coming in
like all the bookings and that with a
profit of 1 500 a month what do you
think we need to repeat this yes
that was actually a wild card because we
aim to get all of our properties within
the central Milton Keynes so this
property we're talking about isn't
within Central Sadie said listen I've
got a wild card I don't know if it's
going to work but it's a beautiful place
let's do it I knew the area anyway so we
kind of just gave it a go and it just it
turned out to be our most profitable
essay what would you have done if it
didn't work did you have bright Clauses
in place of course yeah we had a six
month break clause in place it's a worst
case if it's not making any money yeah
yeah after six months you just hand the
keys back walk away yes exactly how much
money was needed in Turtle to get it all
set up
um about 3 000 because it was already
fully furnished so it was literally just
deposit up front and first month's rent
so 3 000 pounds and then making 1 500
profit a month yeah that's Madness yes
within two months made our money back
yeah and now you still got that
presumably we haven't actually got that
one anymore
one why did the landlord find out how
much money you're making or something so
because this is our first one obviously
it's been a learning curve at the
beginning we didn't have certain things
in place so there was parties that were
thrown at the beginning yeah and the
management of the block got involved it
escalated and we actually ended up
having to give that one back yeah yeah
so that was that would have been the end
of you right there that could have been
yeah did you feel like quitting at that
point were you gutted we were very
gutted
um to be fair the landlord or the
landlady she was very fond of us so even
after the party she was still kind of
fighting our corner to try and keep the
property right because she liked
everything we were doing
um with the property damn so what did
you learn from that in future how do you
stop that happening so we've put so much
in place now so we do minimum two night
bookings we've got cameras in all of our
properties now so we can see what's
going on and yeah we just make sure that
we're vetting the guests before they
come and look more so taken their ID we
take deposits we just make sure that say
they're booking that they don't actually
live in the area already because then
you know they're going to be throwing it
for a party they're interesting that's a
good point Yeah so basically if someone
lives in Milton Keynes but then they
want to book a property in Milton Keynes
for the night
yeah but if they live in in Wales or
London or and they're traveling then it
makes sense that they want to stay there
exactly and then we always try and call
when they've checked in just to make
sure they've checked in okay and Etc and
then you can sort of get a feel for
infants up or whatever but since then
we've not had any issues and the thing
is you've got that deal within three
weeks you got the keys within three
weeks of starting the training so it's
like you know you're gonna make mistakes
on your first deal as it happens the
mistake meant that you had to give the
keys back to the property some people
would have quit at that point what was
it that kept you going do you know what
we knew that it was a mistake that was
made we learned from it and it was just
a case of just onwards and upwards yeah
you know the main thing we thought about
is what can we do what can we put in
place to prevent this from happening
again one thing that really has helped
is the cameras just for the fact that
it's connected to our phones if we see
for example if two people have booked it
to check in if we see more than two
people coming in and certain things
don't add up I can quickly milk cheeses
on that big so I can quickly go over
there and make sure everything's okay
Dan there they wouldn't want that they
wouldn't want that yeah they wouldn't
want that talking of you going over like
now how many properties have you got now
six six presumably you're not having to
go over back and forth yeah right
because you couldn't be no I mean you're
now full-time in property you you you're
financially free you've quit your job
you're still working you enjoy your job
yeah I enjoy my job
um you know what I haven't had to so
what we're doing is
um we can run it while I'm still working
um in future Ventures I'm going to be a
lot more Hands-On so
I most probably will all right excited
we won't say too much yeah but we'll say
watch this space watch this space how
much profit are you making across with
your deal or selling your rent to rent
on average per month right now just from
the property business from the
properties about seven and a half
thousand yeah nice so that's a mixture
of rent to rent and deal selling yeah so
from rent to rent so I'm making about
four and a half the properties I make
about four and a half profit I'm selling
about a dual month yeah so yeah good so
that's like basically that's full-time
salary for two people yeah yes yeah
which is incredible so you quit being an
accountant yeah done
I quit in September so four months after
joining the academy we had four
properties at the time and that enabled
enabled me to leave my job and just go
full time in property how did you enjoy
your job before quitting did you love it
did you not like it oh I was ready to go
why did you not like it it just I just
knew that it wasn't my passion I just
kind of
fell into accountancy like when I left
school like all my friends were off to
University and stuff and it's not what I
wanted to do I went down the accountancy
route but I knew I just didn't have a
passion for it I knew that there was
more out there so leaving my job is it's
just been the best thing ever like now I
can enjoy property I enjoy what I'm
doing I'm more present with my family
and yeah I would recommend it to anyone
I'm gonna say that we talk about this as
well the height what we've noticed in
these kind of companies the higher you
go
the more time you've got sacrifice so
you become a manager the more time
you've got to put in at work you know
you finish work you've got to come home
you kind of bring the work home you're
still working so I think the main thing
with us was time because time is
priceless you know so it's so true you
work you out the corporate ladder get to
the top of the ladder and realize you're
climb the wrong ladder yeah exactly you
know and the many people that here's the
interesting thing many people don't like
their jobs that'd be how you didn't love
accountants say and you got charred as
well so you're pretty high up as an
accountant yeah you know you get
chartered you're an accountant but then
it's like
well what's the other option because you
need the money to be able to pay for the
rent and the mortgage and the car what's
the option so people end up just
spending their whole life until they're
in their 60s or even 70s
doing something they don't like wasting
their life away and that's one of the
reasons why
I set up the academy yeah in the first
place to help people live the life that
they actually want to live so you know
I'm really glad to see that you're
living your best lives too I mean you
make it to what time to retirement age
that's when you're supposed to go and
enjoy your life if you've got you
haven't really got energy right those
kind of Ages you know what I'm saying
you ain't going to the beach with your
beach bars exactly that and I just think
it it just seems like a trap it just
doesn't make sense to me you know and
now as well you're still working right
now in your job but you know that you
could quit if you want if I wanted to I
could quit like that so now you're not a
because now it's like I'll come
because I want to yeah but if someone's
treating you terribly you're not
thinking oh I just have to stomach it
because otherwise I'll be on the streets
I need to pay my bills or but having it
going to work because you you want to as
opposed to have to is a good thing yeah
it's different very different yeah
what's been the most exciting part of of
your experience in property so far for
me it's just
it's just I never would have met
friendships I've made on the academy
it's just been the best bit and as you
talked about earlier the environment
like being surrounded by people that are
on the same path or on similar paths
that just that just want more about a
life that are doing well that are giving
back being surrounded by those sort of
people it's just been the best thing
yeah that's the best thing for me I mean
the academy is priceless you get to meet
people you might not meet in your
everyday life you know and for example
um our latest JV with an academy member
Harry he invested just because we're in
the academy seen what we're doing he
invested 5K into US yeah without even
knowing us properly yeah there's nowhere
else people will do that you know he
just watched our story he liked what it
was about and he yeah he wanted to get
involved and yeah he invested it's
powerful bro the power of the gold badge
Yeah Yeah question as well it's for you
Saturday particularly how do you juggle
you got on the academy before you
perform a year right but how do you
juggle a full-time demanding job as a
chartered accountant
being a mom because your mom right I'm a
mum yeah just the one okay
one two year old hard and trying to set
up a property business having a property
not work out and there's parties you
have to give the keys back
how did you juggle that and how did you
get through that with all the stuff that
you had on at the time so when I was
still working full-time I literally had
to timetable everything that I was doing
I literally had to fit it in fit in
building a property business into the
nooks and crannies of time that I had
and that's something that I learned from
the academy and it was actually Huston
that talked about sort of building their
business doing one hour a day like you
can do it using one hour a day so I was
using my lunch breaks to make calls to
agencies in the evenings when the baby
would go down to sleep that's when I'm
doing my leads and just doing my
viewings on weekends so I just had to
fit it into spare hours of time that I
had you have to bring the baby to view
to bring the baby to viewings and stuff
yep and you know what at the beginning
that was something that I sort of shied
away from I thought oh my gosh if I
bring my son along it's not going to
look professional and things like that
and it's the complete opposite I found
that bringing him along and that's
something that I learned from JL who's
also got a young son she used to just
take her on with her bring bring him
anywhere yeah she does tell me like to
me she'll be like oh can you hold him
for a minute um I'm like okay she's
there I'm about to negotiate give me one
sec he just comes you know they just
like together constantly exactly I
suppose I think as a moment I can't
speak as a mom right I've got three kids
but I'm not a mom but sometimes as a mom
you think when you've got kids I have to
be at home with the kids but actually
you can take them to work yeah take a
what you know if you're going on
viewings and things you can take them
out what did you think um laminate when
you saw how well the results were coming
because I know it was interesting
because you joined the academy like a
year ago yeah nearly April last year
April last year coming up to a year but
then it was about six months later when
then you joined the academy so what was
that about what happened
um I saw what she was doing
um I saw the energy she was bringing as
well
um everything
or we we manifest things as well so it's
a case where I saw everything that we're
manifesting is coming it's it's coming
through all it needs is
um your energy obviously put your energy
in put your work rate in and yeah I saw
everything coming together and I thought
yeah you know what I need to be part of
this and she kept saying you know what
baby you need to join the academy join
the academy because I'm I'm skeptical at
some at times you know like um
but when things make sense to me I mean
yeah I will go but since then you've
been recommending all your friends and
family yeah most definitely we've had a
whole bunch of people come down and
they're like oh let me know and Sadie
you know we know them and with their
friends family whatever which is just
incredible because it's about spreading
the message and a lot of people think
you know they might just watch a YouTube
video and they've never they've never
come to any events they've never had
anyone in their circle that has become
financially free in property and they've
been watching thinking you know really
you know I mean there must be a catch
somewhere what's going on and I guess
the catch is it's hard work yeah it's
it's hustle and grind and the the catch
is you have to invest at some point yeah
we do one pound courses and there's
YouTube but at some point if you want to
get mentored and really trained there's
an investment not just an investment of
money but also an investment of time
you've got to take your kids out on
viewings and I think that's the catch
yeah if you do for 12 months what most
people wouldn't do other Chartered
Accountants they'll see you relaxing
going on viewings in the sun with your
kid and everyone I wish I could do that
but you did what they weren't prepared
to do that's it exactly talk to me about
the hard times what was the most
difficult point when you wanted to quit
if there was one I've never wanted to
quit but the most difficult time was
when we lost that property because I had
just given my notice in yeah and did you
have other properties or was that the
only one no we had um luckily we had a
couple of other properties I think we
had four at the time okay so that one
was going but that was the big earner
that was a grand and a half that was
good it was what like eight nine hundred
yeah right so losing that one just like
I could have quit but in my head it was
never an option of quitting it was just
a case of okay I need to go out and
grind harder to to get some more
properties and that's exactly what we
did so I said you know what we got the
email on the same day as was it the
awards ceremony we got the email that
morning saying that um the block
management company isn't happy for us to
run it as an essay so we gotta take it
off immediately was it immediately or
they gave us a week to take it off at
first I said immediately then they gave
us a bit and it gave us a little bit of
time so it was actually on the day of
the water ceremony your one so yeah so
and how did how did that make you feel
was it like oh now I'm going to be
celebrating everyone's successing people
giving awards and I've had this taken
off me or was it like what was going on
emotionally it was more of we needed a
booster so we needed a war ceremony
would kind of boost us anyway we did it
it definitely definitely definitely and
that's why again coming back to
environment that's so key like if we
didn't have that we probably would have
just stayed more on a low but I'll come
into the academy dinner that evening
just boost us back up and it's like
right okay let's get back up and go
again yeah and that's that's what it
comes down to Life Is Life you know it's
never going to be a smooth sailing
things can happen it's about how you
deal with it yeah you know so there's a
case where we could have moped about and
said oh no this has happened what we're
gonna do now but no that's not us what's
the hardest aspect to running a property
business is it finding the deals is it
pitching the landlord Builds on the
deals is it running the properties and
systemizing it like is it getting the
guests what's the most difficult bit
which involves the most training and and
knowledge definitely getting the deals
at the beginning yeah because it is a
grind and
um I can't remember if I said to you
before but before we came on the academy
um we was trying for a long time to get
service accommodation apartments and
we're just continuously getting nose and
no one was getting what we were trying
to sort of bring to them it's only when
we came on the academy and got training
by yourselves and learned what to do
learn the script that's when we learn
how to get essays that was the most
challenging bit but once we started to
get them it's then okay managing the
essays and then the next challenge is
okay now we need to systemize it so you
have different challenges as you go
along the process on The Mastermind
every week pretty much I always say
you're always gonna have problems yeah
you're never going to be in a situation
where you probably do business because
to begin with the problem might be I fun
to deal then it's I need to find an
investor then it's I need to get the
landlord to agree then it's all I need
the contracts then it's oh there's a
problem with the contract then it's I
need to sit like there's always going to
be a problem yeah it might be the
problem is once you're doing really well
damn now I need to pay tax how can I
save tax and I think on the weekly
masterminds that's why it's really
interesting watching everyone with
different challenges because sometimes
people's challenge might be I'm
struggling with motivation I'm a mom
I've got a job I'm really it's really
tough
but then this might be someone else
that's like I'm making 25 Grand a month
and I've suddenly realized I've got a
massive tax bill how do I save it and
it's just so interesting seeing
everyone's different challenges but
you'll never get to a point where you
don't have challenges by very definition
of an entrepreneur is someone that
solves problems sales programs and keeps
going that's it yeah absolutely yeah
what's your reason why what's your
strongest reason for doing this
we've always wanted it to create kind of
a foundation you know where um our
children don't have to because we we
didn't come from a rich background
um
I feel like we gotta build for our
children give them the best possible
um it's like passing about one give them
the best possible life that they can
live and so they can pass on to their
children and so on so it is my why was
more for Kareem and our future children
as well I also want to help other people
you know like it's not about keeping the
knowledge to yourself it's about
um passing the knowledge on
um
same way people might not want to people
might be working but they hate their
jobs and I get how they feel so it's a
case where if there's another option
where you could do something where you
enjoy what you enjoy doing then yeah I
love to pass that knowledge on and same
thing you do mate I was gonna say like
it's so good that you've got you guys
have such big hearts because a lot of
people they'll become really successful
and then they don't even want to come
and win it on a Wednesday because
they're like oh if I come on when
there's no Wednesday I'll talk about my
strategy in my area everyone's going to
want to do it and it's actually that's a
poverty mindset there's enough business
for everybody to win that's it and when
you think from a position of abundance
you know you end up helping your family
and your friends but then you collab
with them
you know you do deals together yeah
that's it and my why when I first
um got into property my why was for my
son like I had to go back to work after
six months of having him and I wanted to
be more present with him so my wife was
being able to get out of work so I can
be spend more time with him because you
know I've grown up with my mum grinding
I think I get my grind from her so
having property there allowed me to do
that and now I'm in a place where I can
help other mums I can help them get out
of their jobs and show them what's
possible and show them that you know if
you set aside certain amount of time you
can achieve this you can get out of work
you can have Financial Freedom you can
spend more time with your kids it's so
worthwhile and now I can give back and
and help other people and you've done
that massively as well even within the
academy you know like to begin with you
know asking Lots questions learning but
now I know you still are continuing to
learn and you're continuing to grow your
own success but you've been a massive
asset to the academy and just by sharing
and giving back and encouraging other
people it's um and that's really what
it's about so huge respect what will be
your final words of wisdom or biggest
piece of advice to someone watching this
video that's thinking I really want to
get started in property I really want to
start making money but maybe they've um
they're wondering how do I get started
I'd say just do it and get get educated
you know come down to a one pound crash
course that's what we tell all our
friends and family as well you know come
and see Samuel leads get educated
because we wouldn't be here without you
and your training and we're so grateful
for you and everything that you do
because you know you've changed our
lives you know just in a short amount of
time that we've been on your courses
you've changed our life so yeah I will
tell anyone to just just go and do it
and don't think that you can do it on
your own it's good to be around the
right people the right environment is so
important so yeah just get down and get
educated I appreciate that and there's
no point trying to reinvent the wheel
you know if something's if there's a way
of doing something it's like if you want
to learn to be an electrician you're
going to go to college and learn how to
be an electrician you're not going to
try and figure out from trial and error
you're going to end up getting electric
shock and in the same way in property
like you you were trying to get rent to
rent before joining the academy and you
kept saying the wrong thing kick your
nose it's disheartening man just get the
script yeah just keep going don't give
up yeah ever if we if we gave up we
wouldn't be where we're yeah oh no you
know so um we've got so many knows so
many so many estate agents so many
landlords nah we're friends with a lot
of estate agents who pass us the deals
that's true so success breeds success
that's it yeah yeah even just yesterday
we had a message from a landlord didn't
we saying that he's got hmos that he's
happy to give to us and we can rent it
out room by room so yeah gotta go meet
him next week yeah yes first it's hard
but the more deals you get the easier it
is and you can also use your first
dealer's credibility toward the
landlords so now well massive thank you
for coming down onto the show I really
appreciate it guys you heard it here
first that was Sadie and lamina they say
themselves biggest advice come down to
the one pound property investor school
so you know what I'm gonna do right now
I'm going to leave a link in the
description where you can book a ticket
to come and meet with me spend the full
day together learning about property the
property investors crash course one
pound what are you waiting for get
booked and we'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you